>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> My name is Sydney Trent,
and I'm a senior editor
at the Washington Post.
I edit for the Washington
Post magazine and for Style.
And I am also a mother
of two young girls.
And so I'm particularly happy to
be here in the children's tent,
because I know that when you're
really trying to get children
to read, with all the
competition that's out there --
video, TV, texting -- that you
really need great children's book
authors to get them
attached to the books.
And there's no better friend
than a really wonderful
children's book author.
And we have one here
today, and that is Pat Mora.
[Applause]
Okay. Pat Mora...is a -- she's a
literacy advocate, and she's excited
about what she calls "bookjoy".
She founded the family literacy
initiative, El Dia de los Ninos,
El Dia de los Libros,
Children's Day, Book Day,
now housed at the American
Library Association.
The year-long commitment to daily
linking all children to books,
languages and cultures
culminates in celebrations
across the country on
or near April 30th.
Her book titled Book Fiesta,
Celebrate Children's Day, Book Day,
Celebremos El Dia de los
Ninos, El Dia de los Libros,
HarperCollins, promotes
the Dia spirit.
Mora's haiku collection about
foods of the Americas, "Yum!
Mmm! Que rico!"
-- I wish I could roll my Rs, but --
won the Americas award and
was an ALA notable book.
"Dona Flor, A Tall Tale
About a Giant Woman
With a Great Big Heart" was
also an ALA notable book
that received a Pura Belpre Author
Honor Award and a Golden Kite Award
from the Society of Children's
Book Writers and Illustrators.
Mora lives in New Mexico.
And here she is.
[ Applause ]
>> It is so great to be
back at the book festival.
This is my third visit.
The first one I was sick as a dog.
The second one I was afraid
I would be sick again.
And this one I didn't
even worry, so --
buenos tardes, thank
you all for being here.
I would have been very sad
to be in the tent by myself.
So I thank you.
It's a little toasty.
There's no doubt about that.
And there's part of
me a little longing
for a little New Mexico breeze,
but there's nothing quite
like the National Book Festival, and
one of the things we're encouraged
to do is not to read to you,
but to chat a little bit
about what we do and why we do it.
I had the wonderful experience in
the media tent a little bit ago
to be interviewed by kids.
And I have to tell you, I write
both for adults and children,
but for those of us who do both,
there is nothing like the affection
of young people, you know.
So my friends who write only
for adults don't know what they are
missing, because kids have a way
of making us feel like rock stars.
So I had three little
kids from close
by who had all prepared
wonderful questions.
They were not bilingual,
but they were kids who were
in a bilingual immersion school,
and I loved their questions.
And then there was a group
of students from Delaware
who have their own
television program.
And they were here, and each
child asked me questions.
So...I coined the word
"bookjoy", because I so love books.
I love reading them and
I love writing them.
And one of the things that both
groups of children asked me is,
what's the best thing
about your job?
And I said, "Well, probably that
I get to spend time by myself."
And that's an odd thing
for young people growing
up in our very noisy culture,
I think, to understand.
But in point of fact, we
can't be talking to them
about reading, if we're not readers.
So I spend a lot of my life
talking to teachers and librarians.
How many of you are
teachers or librarians?
God bless you, you know.
God bless you.
That is such hard work.
And you all are the people who
often connect what we do as authors
with the kids in your more
and more diverse classrooms.
And if we're going to
have a democracy at all --
and one of the great things
about the book festival is,
it has now become bipartisan, right?
So it was started during the Bush
administration by Laura Bush.
I'm a Texan by birth.
And she brought the Texas
Book Festival to DC.
But the great thing is, now with the
Obamas we still have the National
Book Festival, and
we heard last night
that a very generous donor
has guaranteed five more years
of funding.
[Applause]
I also want to be sure to say for
all these people in the red shirts,
that in my other life I was
a university administrator,
and staff never get respect.
So I do -- you know, I thank all the
people at the Library of Congress.
Yeah, it's an amazing
job [applause].
It's an amazing job.
I have a wonderful young man sitting
quietly back here hoping nobody will
notice him, named David, who has
taken care of me all day long,
and without him I would
not have been here on time.
I would not, you know,
seemed fairly calm.
So I can't say enough
about the volunteers.
I'm gonna touch on a few
books, and then mostly
on the book that's being
featured here in Book Fiesta.
A couple of the new books I have --
one of the questions people ask is,
where do you get your
ideas for books?
And I have on my computer
a list of the books I want
to write while I'm on this earth.
And so I add to that list, and
sometimes one of the books kind
of moves up, but I'm
-- but sometimes --
not always, but sometimes
-- people give me ideas.
And at first when people say,
"I know the next book
you should write,"
I actually tense up a little bit.
Because I'm very protective
about this list
that I've got on my computer, right?
And I don't want them to
feel that they're orphans,
and that I'm not gonna
get back to them.
But in fact, the last recent books
-- one, "Dizzy, Poems About Love,"
was a Texas librarian who said,
"Why don't you write a book
of love poems for teens?"
And I kind of burst out laughing,
and I said, "Love poems for teens?"
And then I started asking teachers
and librarians as I traveled,
and here was what tipped it.
One librarian said, "Yes, because,
not only do the girls read them,
but the boys read them
and sign their names."
And though I may be
against plagiarism,
that was a temptation
I could not pass up.
That was a joyous, joyous
book for me to write.
And then, because teachers and
librarians often say to me,
you know, I want to do what you do.
I want to be a writer, but
my colleagues don't know.
Tell me what to do.
So I actually wrote a book
of letters called "Zing,
Seven Practices for Educators and
Their Students," about seven ways
that I think we can
foster our own creativity.
We are all creative, right?
Everybody in the tent is creative.
It's just we need to foster that.
And then, if we need to
foster it, how do we foster
that feeling in all of our students.
And of course for me the
emphasis is always the word all.
Not in some of our students,
but all of our students.
Book Fiesta also involved -- evolved
by by someone sort of suggesting it.
I had started -- it'll
be 15 years in April --
and my wonderful web team is here,
so I have to be sure to tell you
that we worked very
hard on the website,
and I hope you will visit it,
because there's a lot of information
about this literacy --
family literacy project,
that's on the website.
And we started out -- it's
got a long name, right?
So it gives you a chance
to practice your Spanish.
It's called El Dia de los
Ninos, El Dia de los Libros,
Children's Day, Book Day.
And I really started it when I
was being interviewed in Arizona
and someone said to me, "Will you
tape some of your books in Spanish?
Some of my books are in
English, some are bilingual.
And -- because I want to
play them on the radio."
And I said, "Well, for what?"
And she said, "Well,
for Dia del Nino."
And I said, "Gee, I'm
from the border,
and I've never heard of this."
And she said, "Oh, yes, in
Mexico on April 30th the schools
and the parents have this
big celebration for kids,
and maybe it's a picnic
or treats or whatever."
So I walked out of the building,
and it was like something hit me
on the head, and I thought, well,
we oughtta have Children's
Day, Book Day.
You know, we have such a literacy
challenge in this country.
We heard statistics last night,
one of 'em I'm still reeling from,
that 80% of the families
in this country did not
buy one book last year.
And I'm trying to believe
that's not true.
But, we know that we have
a real literacy crisis.
And, you know, if we
don't have readers,
pretty soon we don't have people
who understand what's going
on in our political life, and in
our financial life, etc., etc.,
etc. So I do feel passionately
about this, because I'm lucky enough
to be a reader, and I think
every one of you is, too, right?
So, when we've been given this gift
that we didn't earn, somehow we have
to share it, and that's
really what Dia is all about.
So the -- in April we will have
the 15th anniversary, and schools
and libraries plan
something special,
book parades and, you
know, contests.
Usually they give away free books.
And so, if you come from a community
that isn't celebrating Dia,
I am deputizing you
to go out and do this.
So the book was actually evolved
-- it's called "Book Fiesta".
The illustrations are unbelievable.
And when I visit elementary schools
-- and I'm very lucky, you know,
because I write for both
adults and children,
sometimes in the same day I may
go talk to graduate students
about the adult work, and
in the afternoon I go talk
to second-graders.
And sometimes the second-graders
pay more attention
than the graduate students.
But the -- it's always a
disappointment to the kids
when I say to them, now, you know,
I did not do the illustrations.
And I see on their little
faces that they're thinking,
then why did we invite you
to our school [laughter]?
And when they ask me -- and the
students did this morning, you know,
they said, well, why -- have you
ever illustrated your own book?
And I said, "Well, if
you'd ever seen me draw,
you wouldn't ask that."
You know, some years back,
when Pictionary was so popular,
my family was playing it and
nobody wanted to be my partner.
But I'm incredibly grateful
to the illustrators.
You know, for picture books
the illustrator is key.
So an editor happened to say to
me, well, I want to do something
to help promote the Dia concept, you
know, this idea of children's day,
book day, and linking all children
to books, languages and cultures.
And she said, "So we
ought to produce a book."
She was an editor with
HarperCollins.
And initially she said, "Well,
I think it should be a story."
And I said, "Well, it's
gonna be kind of a tough --
a tough thing to write a story."
I had already written, some
of you know the book "Tomas
and the Library Lady," about --
a true story about Tomas Rivera,
a migrant worker from Crystal
City, Texas, who, thanks to books
and a wonderful librarian in
his life, his wonderful parents,
he went on to become the
president of the University
of California at Riverside.
So it was an amazing journey
that this little boy made,
and I love to talk to
children about this book.
Because, you know, we say to
them anybody can be President.
But in a way, we're a little
cynical about that, right?
I mean, we are a little
cynical about that.
But with Tomas's story, we really
have a concrete and true example
of a boy whose family
did not speak English,
did not have economic resources, but
he goes on and, yes, there's the,
you know, the -- a
librarian takes an interest
in him, his family supports him.
Parts that are not in
the book for children
but that I think it's
important that we know.
When he got his first degree,
he was an English major
in the state of Texas.
Nobody was gonna hire
him to teach English.
Why? He was bilingual.
How could someone who was
bilingual teach English.
So I like we've progressed
beyond some of this, right?
But the other thing that I find
about talking about Tomas is,
kids have no idea what
a migrant worker is.
And sometimes the kids who don't
know what a migrant worker is have
migrant families, you
know, maybe two miles away.
So as I say to kids, how do we think
the strawberries got to the store?
You know. The idea that someone
is bending over in the hot sun,
this whole piece of how we eat those
delicious red bites is somehow lost
on our kids.
So Tomas was a great
way to talk about that,
and I felt that to do another
book like that, a story,
I didn't know that that was
going to be the thing for Dia.
So this book really, I wanted
to show kids how books are
wonderful in outrageous places.
And so the way I wrote it, and
the way the illustrator did it,
is that the kids are reading their
books in the hot air balloon,
they're reading their books
in the mouth of a whale,
on top of an elephant,
and it just keeps reinforcing
that idea
of just the pleasure of reading.
I was interviewed a few minutes
ago by a publication that works
with childcare workers, and they
asked me, "Well, what would you say
to people who are working with
the really little ones about how
to use these bilingual
books," because I mentioned
that in honest moments, sometimes
teachers and librarians would say
to me, "Well, I would like
to use the bilingual books,
but I'm not bilingual."
And I love to stress the fact that,
you know, if you're at the front
of a room, just like if you're
at the head of the family,
right, you have a lot of power.
Teachers and librarians
have a lot of power.
And so if you're holding up
and sharing bilingual books,
what you're saying to
your bilingual students,
whether they speak Japanese or
Arabic at home, you're saying,
you know, languages matter,
languages are beautiful.
And to say to those kids, you
know, I only speak one language,
how many of you speak more than one?
I love this story.
I visited one -- an
international school in Colorado.
One of the little guys
spoke five languages.
So I say to kids, never
think there isn't room
in your head for these languages.
Of course there is.
I want to be sure we
have time for questions.
And we have a timekeeper
with a big smile up here.
So I'm hoping you're
gonna have questions.
We have a mike here.
Is that it?
All right.
Oh, and a mike there.
So although I haven't talked about,
you know, a lot of the other books,
you can ask me about
whatever you want,
but don't leave me
up here by myself.
So be bold.
I always say to audiences,
if you were third-graders,
you would all have lined up.
>> When you write about in Spanish,
and you write about in English,
do you think that the thought of
Spanish, like Spanish will overcome
in certain way the English.
What I want to mean is,
I am that teacher of ESL.
I have teach four years.
My first language is Spanish.
So my drama is, should I
transfer the strength of English
like English, or should
I reserve that strength
of the Spanish and the English.
>> Alright, it's a great
question about, you know,
Spanish was his first
language, and -- I am bilingual.
All of my grandparents came
from Mexico at the time
of the Mexican Revolution.
However, I have always
been bilingual.
So I have no memory
of not speaking both.
And because I have spent my entire
professional life in English,
I always say I am bilingual,
but English dominant.
I know all the rules in English.
I know when I can break them and
when I can't, although I have
to say I heard more
grammatical errors this morning
from some very -- people
in very prestigious places.
So we all know that, you know --
what we talk about English
grammar is changing every minute.
So I start out in English.
I did do one long poem -- I
had two wonderful parents.
When my dad died, I wanted
to do really something
special to honor him.
And so I did a long poem
completely in Spanish.
And that was a real challenge,
not because of the Spanish,
but because I did a
poetic form popular
on the border called the corrido.
So I was both learning the form, and
I was sitting in Cincinnati, Ohio,
with my Spanish-English dictionary
and a book about the form.
But you know we do
things to honor people.
So I think, you know,
as a teacher BLL,
what I say to kids is I want
them to be able to speak English
and whatever their
other home language is.
I want them to be able to read it,
write it and speak it really well.
The truth of the matter is that
kids who do not speak English
in this country are often
still viewed as second-class.
So for those of you who work with
students who are not, you know,
dominant in English, they are
wrestling with -- internally --
with this sense that am
I really good enough?
And it just drives me crazy,
which is one of the reasons I feel
so passionately about linking
all children to books, languages,
in the plural, and cultures.
How about on this side?
>> Hi. I am a third-grade
teacher, and we are going to be,
in our shared reading, reading
about Tomas and the Library Lady,
but in my guided reading,
we're going to be reading a
little book about your life.
They -- my kids know that
I've come to see you today,
and I wanted to ask you
what message would you
like me to take back to them?
>> Well, it's always the same
message, which is to be readers.
I want them to be readers.
And I think the hard thing,
when we're particularly --
if we're working with parents,
and, you know, when I say parents
who are not readers, those could
be really wealthy parents, right?
Today the fact that someone isn't
a reader doesn't have to do just
with your economic state.
But I think, you know, we
want kids to feel that --
and that's part of the Dia
message -- that reading is fun.
You know, that it's
not a punishment.
I stress this with
parents all the time.
It should never be a punishment.
I mean, it's an utter pleasure.
Some of us got to hear the editor
of the New Yorker this morning,
and he was simply eloquent.
And he spoke about
fear of being alone.
And in my book for educators, Zing,
that's the second practice
I recommend,
that you have to cultivate a
willingness to be alone, right?
To be a reader or to be a writer,
you have to grow comfortable
with being alone.
That can be hard sometimes, when
we say that to young people.
I was in my hometown of El Paso,
Texas, last week and I was speaking
to about a thousand kids,
pre-service teachers
who were reading Zing.
And some of them had said to their
professors, "Ooh, I don't know if I
like this idea of wanting quiet."
You know, I say cultivate
a pleasure in quiet.
But we need to stress that.
If you don't have quiet,
how are you gonna think,
and how are you gonna hear yourself?
>> Hi. I'm a student, and I
recently had an assignment
in my creative writing class to
write from a child's point of view,
and I found it kind of difficult.
And I was wondering how you
find it so easy to write
from a child's point
of view in your books.
>> It's probably 'cause I'm
still a child [laughter].
And really, I think there's a
lot of truth to that, you know.
I think that part of what happens
over time, when you first sit
down -- and I try to talk
about this in Zing --
that it takes a while to get rid
of all those what are people
gonna think, how'm I gonna sound,
what are people gonna say.
The more you write, the more
when you get to that page,
you're kinda curious about
what you're gonna say.
And so I really do try to get lost
in the child that I am writing about
or writing for, and I'm trying
not to hear anything else.
So if -- you're still hearing the
other people in your class, right?
And over time, if you keep doing
it, you won't hear them any more.
>> Thank you.
>> How many schools have you
been, and when the students come,
are they excited and do they
be polite or do they be rude?
>> Well, first of all, I think
we should clap for you for going
up to ask a question [applause].
That was very brave.
You know, I visit some schools,
as I say, because I write
for grown-ups and for children.
I visit both, so I visit -- and
I speak at a lot of conferences.
I don't know how many
schools I've visited.
They are almost always polite.
And I was a teacher before I started
writing, so if they're not polite,
I kind of stop everything,
you know, how teachers do.
And I say, well, if you're
gonna talk, I'm not gonna talk.
And so usually they're very polite.
And what I love best is
sometimes when I visit a school,
and they maybe have
memorized some of my poems,
and they let me hear them.
That's a real treat.
So thank you again.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi. I am a teacher educator,
and I didn't get to hear all
of your talk, but the part
that I heard I really thank
you for and appreciate.
I do use your children's books
with my pre-service teachers,
and one of the things that
I'm wondering if you find this
with other people, but my
students are primarily white
and English-speaking, and
they don't like Dona Flor.
And I don't know if
it's because they --
and there's a couple of other books.
There's -- I can't think of
the name of it right now,
but a book about a legendary
character who's African-American,
and they don't like that one either.
And if they can't get their minds
around a legend that's not white,
and so I don't know if
that is something that --
>> What a fascinating
thing for you to say.
If I were you, I would really
try to get behind some of that,
either by having them do kind of
private writing, you know, to you.
But just trying to create an
atmosphere where they could talk
about why, because in a sense the
whole idea is, I am empowering.
I mean, for those of you
who don't know Dona Flor,
it's the Paul Bunyan
legend that inspired it.
But it's an immense, bilingual
woman with a great big heart.
Are we out of time?
Oh, over time.
That's what I would do.
>> Thank you.
I appreciate it.
And I do -- maybe saying
don't like is a little strong.
They don't believe it.
And I keep saying, it's not
supposed to be believable.
It's a legend.
>> Right. It's a tall tale.
Well, I will be signing books later.
I would love to chat
with all of you.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you [applause].
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.